[MUSIC]
No more love for Ofunato
Maybe
let me talk
about how
to say it  I met you 5. I want you
to
repair my broken ship and take care of
me.At that time, I still didn't know that he was a ship.
I heard you weren't
there, but I
think things have changed since you met
me.
At
first,
they might have thought of running away,
but in the end,
they fought alongside us to
respond to
Kagura's feelings.  I believe you too I believe in
the
way you say it
He's the one who understands when he speaks
I want to be able to smile and talk again Okay
let me turn the
[music] off [music]
okay I'll give
you guys time  Library 16,
Tokoro Cha So let's make a relationship right away
No, it's good that we can't go alone on
this day.
How to leave Funato I don't think it will go down
What will you do then